Hale everybody and welcome to you a
brand new video today him to be having a
look at runescape trillionaires do they
exist and if so who are they a lot of
people had opinions of who actually was
the richest person in runescape however
a lot of the information is a little
sketchy I'm not quite believable so
we're gonna have to go have a look at
all of them and see if they were lying
or not I'm pretty well now have three
people here who were definitely very
wealthy however they are claiming they
had over a trillion dollars each of them
and there is images to back it up I even
one of them has a gmod confirming it
however is it believable I don't know
and before I get started I'm not
doubting the fact that there are
runescape trillionaires in existence
however I feel like if I was a
trillionaire I wouldn't tell [__]
anyone so I do think there are
trillionaires out there but they're
probably keeping a low profile that's
what I would do and that makes the most
sense alright guys hope you enjoy and
let's get started so start off here one
of the most infamous people to claim
that they are chilling there is mulcher
next or Brandon Fisher so he's well
known for being a trillionaire but he's
also well known for beating up his
parents with aluminum baseball bat and
going to jail so if we assume all of
these images aren't photoshopped or
anything there is proof that is showing
that actually his total net worth was
over 9 trillion so not even just
breaking the cusp of a trillionaire he
was in theory the richest person pretty
much who exists in runescape so the real
question is do you believe this I mean
he's probably a compulsive liar beat up
his family and went to jail so he's not
really the most believable person a lot
of people seem to believe that molten X
found a way to abuse the wealth
evaluator function so the screenshot
with all of his accounts and the wealth
evaluator on all of them is just
incorrect it's not to say he wasn't one
of the wealthiest persons in the game
because he can the only really fuzzy
things so much however these particular
numbers may not be 100% accurate now
next up is Twilight Ash who apparently
had over two trillion runescape gold he
made his first bills from merging and
was definitely one of the wealthier
people in runescape but he's most famous
for having a stack of over 1.6 mill
theories at the time of this picture
here had the furies were probably worth
about 1
25 mil each or somewhere around that
leading them to have around 2.2 to 2.5
trillion GP and the kicker here is that
there was even 8 J mod that verified
this picture and said it was a hundred
percent true so it sounds good and dandy
Alton seems like you may have actually
been a trillionaire however later was
proven that a J mod actually got
reprimanded and the post was deleted a
lot of this is kind of hearsay you have
to take all of this information with a
bit of grain of salt and that is kind of
why when I originally made the video and
who was a virtuous person runescape I
went with Jesse just because she had a
lot more documentation of the items that
she had seemed a lot harder to fake
everything that she had whereas these
guys really there's not a lot of proof
for any of it today those Furies would
be worth about three point three
trillion just in case you were wondering
however unfortunately may not have
actually been true and the last appear
is milky now they were originally a
Dicer and a Staker and he was set by
their clan mates i have about 1.5
trillion GP now there is this image here
that's kind of gets circulated around
pretty frequently i've tons of party
hats
christmas crackers the half drugs of
wine which right if you don't know it's
actually a rare in runescape now this
image here was only really said to be
part of his bank so a there's not really
any confirmation for the rest of it so
it's hard to prove if this was actually
true that being said milky was one of
the richest people in runescape and was
more confirmed to have around half a
trillion all right guys that is the
three claimed trillionaires that I could
find really it seems like almost all of
them have been disproven mulcher next
went to jail compulsive liar and
possibly just abused the wealth
calculator however on paper it seems
like yet nine trillion GP Twila Ash
seemed to be legit with his stack of 1.6
Miller is I've ever seemed to be later
just proven because the Jay mod in
question may not have been telling the
truth
in theory Twilight could have had around
two trillion RS GP and last up milky
really not a lot information on it just
kind of hearsay said to have about 1.5
trillion so in the end I'm not sure how
believable any of this is I think maybe
together between of three of them maybe
they had a trillion I don't know but I
think a lot of it was just false
information digging to see if any of
these trillionaires were actually legit
I was actually pretty fun if you're
interested I could go over some of the
more public
sighs wealthy players and guys hope you
enjoyed the video if you did don't
forget to leave it a like and I will see
it in the next one